during the commercial break i gathered
the den nets together and i said
should we play something that manik said
back in september about the lakers
and it was universal everybody said yes
so this is what manic said
about the lakers you know i get killed
every year talking with the lakers with
you because
i tend to be more skeptical as i was
last season but
is it not more likely that the lakers
missed the playoffs than
than the championship i i think that
wait this year right now this year you
so the odds are better that they miss
the playoffs than they win the
championship
i would say so yes wow okay let's bring
in chris mannix who joins us
from the bubble do you stand by that
kind of impossible to stand by that man
i was just trying to give you an out
there if uh no no
i mean at the time
were you know bringing in a bunch of new
players i know anthony davis was one of
them
at the time lebron james was coming off
the most significant injury of his
career
uh it seemed more likely that they
missed the playoffs you don't have to
defend yourself i'm just having fun
you're a great guy
you're a great sport i'd like to defend
myself because it
stood true back then i think that was
correct me from wrong but that was like
late september early october i mean yeah
like that
come on no that's not even one of my
greatest hits
like that's not even oh it's not no no
well
paulie can we queue up some of mannix's
greatest hits here to be more specific
[Laughter]
do you think this is it for greg
popovich
it's a tough call i mean he didn't leave
any breadcrumbs last night
after the game there's
there's long been an assumption that
popovich would be done
after the 2020 olympics obviously those
didn't happen right now so perhaps
we could see him coach one more year and
then
right up into the sunset after the
olympics in 2021
but you know next year is very cloudy
dan like
what's gonna happen uh with the start of
the season i mean
there was some reporting by espn this
week that michelle roberts
who i spoke to last week told the
players that be prepared for a start
time in january
or in march um you know will pop [ __ ]
look at that and say look i got a team
that's
not a contender i want to coach in the
olympics no matter what
uh do i walk away and hand the reins off
to somebody else so
even though he didn't you know say he
was done now
i think there'll be a lot of thought
into going into that over the next few
months
and i thought he positioned becky
hammond to take over
for him and and i talked to nancy
lieberman the hall of famer about this
and then he brings in tim duncan does
tim duncan want to be a head coach
i don't get that sense i don't get that
sense that tim duncan wants
i think tim duncan likes the coaching
part i i don't think he likes everything
else that goes along with it
which includes media responsibilities
and
uh maybe the politics of being a head
coach as well i'm not sure it's it would
be becky hammond either i mean i think
there's
you know there are a lot of ex spurs out
there that are part of the popovich
coaching tree
uh what happens if brett brown gets let
go in philadelphia they've got a very
close relationship pop and brett brown
imei udoka was an assistant coach on pop
staff before going to philadelphia
he's very highly regarded as brett
brown's lead assistant so
i think those the current staff would be
candidates but
i think they'd extend the search pretty
far uh wodge just
announced that the bulls have fired jim
boylan
and it's it felt like a long time coming
and it felt like if you didn't fire him
you were gonna have a player revolt i
mean what
where have the bulls been since michael
jordan left
i mean in a perpetual state of
rebuilding
with one misstep after another now
they've been pretty decent at drafting
over the years you know i mean derrick
rose was a slam dunk but you know they
got jimmy butler late in the first round
and
you know joking no was drafted when
nobody thought he was going to be the
player
he turned out to be but with free agency
with some of these coaching hires
it just hasn't it hasn't gone their way
and and look it's
it's curious that it took them this long
you know the explanation that was given
to me
about why the bulls were waiting this
long
on jim boylan was that there was only
one other coaching opening
and they weren't gonna hire the team
that was gonna the the coach the team
was gonna hire that was tom thibodeau
in new york so they didn't feel a sense
of urgency there may be more
urgency now dan one of the reasons i
think that the timing of this
is is right now is because you have
teams going home
and you've got the pelicans going home
and other teams will be bowing out and
there could be coaching changes
on those staffs the pelicans you know
widely believed to at some point will
let go of alvin gentry
philadelphia you know brooklyn is going
to have an opening at some point maybe
the bulls
want to get started on their search now
to try to get a jump on some of these
other teams
yeah i was just talking about the
pelicans and mclovin said
who would you invest in right now if
they were stocks the pelicans or the
suns
and i actually paused and said i might
go with the sons first of all i love
their coach
and booker has taken that next step i
don't i don't know how good they are
uh as a team moving forward but there's
less drama in phoenix
than the potential drama that you have
in new orleans
lonzo ball mailed it in uh brandon
ingram restricted free agent
zion's health is always going to be an
issue and you might be firing your coach
other than that so who would you invest
in
it to me it's it's six to one and pick
them there i mean it's it
i i like i like the suns because i think
devin booker
has shown in these seating games and
this season in general
that he can be a franchise player i'd
like the suns more
if they had drafted luka doncic and not
drafted the android 8 in that spot i'm
not
i'm not a huge hating guy i've watched
him pretty closely as the sons have made
this rise
he's a little passive around the rim he
doesn't have great hands i just
there's something about him that thing i
think has a bit of a ceiling
and that would give the sun's assume but
you're right about monty williams he's
going to be the
the coach of the seating games as the
nba is going to hand out those awards
in the next couple of days um the the
issue
i had the the reason i would lean
towards the pelicans look zion was hurt
this year but how many guys have we seen
hurt in their first
second years i mean joel embiid missed
like two full seasons and then he was
just fine
i think zion's gonna be okay and i'm a
big believer in brandon ingram i mean
brandon ingram is a star on the rise
oh i love him but is he gonna what's he
gonna cost you
you know he's gonna stay he's a max no
he's a max guy on the second contract
everybody's a max guy in the second
contract
that is like around that that range and
that second contract
isn't enormous by nba standards so uh
i those two guys i like more
long term than booker and ayton as a
twosome
we're talking to chris manick sports
illustrated nba senior writer you were
there to watch the blazers and the nets
i've been giving credit to the nets
because those guys are playing
hard they you know this is their chance
to showcase and they did not stop
the blazers i know you're high on the
blazers you were on that bandwagon
before anybody else it feels like
they're limping towards the finish line
and they looked exhausted last i
wouldn't be surprised if memphis
won the first game between these two i i
wouldn't be surprised at all
well i mean first off quickly on the
nets like
i walked past them at their practice all
the time i was in their practice
i could name like four guys off the top
of my head that are on that team
and it's like the guys that have been
around joe harris and jared allen what
jack vaughn did
with this group going five and three is
nothing short of david copperfield like
magic i mean it's it's incredible
the job he did there um the blazers
i liked seeing cj mccollum get off last
night the way he was playing
after having a real struggle in the
previous game and the report coming out
about the broken back
to see him play that way gave me a
little bit more encouragement about the
blazers
in the playoffs but they don't defend
anybody and they haven't really defended
anybody
throughout these eight seating games
nurkic
makes a lot of mistakes at that five
spot i don't think the grizzlies can
give them a lot of trouble i mean the
grizzlies got in because
giannis head-butted martz wagner and uh
logged her and then
they were missing him and didn't make
him to play for for milwaukee i don't
think they
they take that game off i think the
blazers get in but i'm
far less bullish on portland's chances
to
upset the lakers now than i was maybe at
the start of this when they were fully
healthy
uh and and they were looking like a team
on the rise i just think
the mccollum injury bothers me and as
several coaches have said to me when
i've raised this question to them in the
bubble
who defends lebron like you can do well
i'll say all you want about the
backcourt and the frontcourt
who defends lebron it's an interesting
storyline dan because i mean carmelo
versus lebron and perhaps carmelo's last
chance to
to do something meaningful in the
postseason but i don't know how
i don't know how they pull that off but
you got lillard and mccollum
and anthony and gary trent jr those guys
are among the top six guys as far as
minutes played
and now you're going into at least you
got one more game maybe a couple games
here with memphis
and then you go in against the lakers
and you're right about
you know the lakers haven't been
shooting well but the blazers might be
just what they need
to go against the team that doesn't play
defense
it's true but i mean the lakers have
been getting open looks
i mean some of the games i've been at
like these looks the lakers are getting
are open they're just missing them
and you know j.r smith i think he's
shooting like 16
from from three point range uh and
you're going to rely on dion waiters and
some of these other guys to
to make shots i mean they're really
they're really vulnerable
at this stage maybe not in the first
round but uh you know outside
i mean you heard lebron say after the
game where kyle kuzma made that
game-winning three like he's like we
need him to be our third best player
i mean they need a consistent kyle kuzma
uh to win anything in this whole thing
you know what you're gonna get from
lebron ads been great as well
but they need kuzma to be efficient to
score
15 to 20 points uh and if they don't get
that
they're vulnerable to any team in this
bracket
i think a.d has to be superstar he's got
to be the best player on the floor
i think kuzma has to look like an
all-star
and lebron is going to fill in the gray
area there
but that's that's asking a lot you know
it really is because i still look at the
clippers and say
it feels like the clippers are exactly
where they want to be
we're not really talking about them you
know they they don't make headlines
they're going to have everybody together
and it feels like doc may
may have something here and he knows it
too
well the clippers to me are going to be
a test
of can you flip that proverbial switch i
i think they'll win
that first round match up handily
against the mavericks because dallas is
just
limping into the playoffs right now with
the way they're playing
uh but beyond that you know that they
you mentioned the guys they have all
their guys back but they're just getting
them back they're just trickling in
montrese harrell
uh a front runner for six man is gonna
make his debut tonight you know for the
clippers so
you know getting these guys up to speed
and on the same page
on the fly when you're basically playing
every other day
is going to be a challenge now it's a
challenge that is a little bit more
you know manageable when you have kawhi
leonard and paul george has played well
uh during this this run-up but i mean
chemistry matters
continuity matters and the clippers
haven't had any of it you know for the
last
for the better part of the last month so
if they get a tough matchup in that
second round
uh you know i think they're vulnerable
as well and the east looks like a mess
that the first round match-ups doesn't
look like
there's any surprises in store there
right
no no probably not but i think it gets
fascinating when you get past that
i mean yeah like it's strange to say but
the way
the way milwaukee's kind of been up and
down and giannis has been frustrated
throughout this whole process
um you almost have to make the raptors a
co-favorite right now which is the most
remarkable thing you could possibly say
like
you mentioned my idiot comment back in
september about the lakers like
the idea that the raptors could be
sitting here as a conference contender
as a
potential co-favor to go to the finals
is insane
i mean this team and i've been watching
them a lot down here in the bubble and
some of the observations are they're an
incredibly smart team like a high iq
team
from like one to ten like they make the
right play way more often than not
and when i talk to raptors executives
there the one thing they often say
is that kawhi leonard's gone but kawhi
leonard still lives with this team
like the the mental toughness that kawhi
instilled on these young guys like
like ogi ananobi and pascal siakam and
fred vanvleet
like that still lingers with this team
and that's that's actually something
that's going to help them
as they get into the playoffs so they've
got questions too you know can ciaco
make that leap in the postseason
can vanvleet make another jump in the
postseason but the way the bucks have
played i mean i think they're vulnerable
as well and the raptors might be the
team
because of their size that could be the
one that takes them out
i love what the heat have done i love
what pat riley's done with that i mean
it's really amazing
when you think you know wade retiring
lebron leaves
bosch has to retire and all of a sudden
he just
starts to get a couple of draft picks
and
you know out of bio came out of nowhere
it felt like
jimmy butler there wants to be there and
play with that team
duncan robinson they find i mean
tyler hero it's it's an interesting team
i don't know
if it's a great team but boy pat riley
did
him he did a great job really he did he
did and how
like how you build successful teams is
hitting
on those mid-round picks and and further
back right you
you're supposed to hit on those top
level picks but what they've done with
tyler hero
what they've done with bam adebayo is
going to be the most improved player
this year
duncan robinson undrafted you watch
duncan robinson play
and you're looking around like what did
people miss with this guy i mean he's
like six
eight and makes threes and has that kind
of mindset where he always wants the
ball
so what did we teams miss with that guy
the one
you know where the heat missed and where
i'm sure and i know that the heat front
office and the coaching staff
think about this all the time especially
down here in the bubble was
and i forgot was it the 2015 draft when
they drafted justice winslow and they
could have had devin booker
they loved devin booker he had he had an
unbelievable workout for them
uh down in miami and there was a big
split within that organization
about devin booker over justice winslow
if they had devin booker right now dan
you know we'd be looking at the heat in
a whole new light we we mentioned don
that's a recent example but booker
winslow i mean that that's a big turning
point for an organization
all right so make a prediction here oh
great
great uh paulie are we rolling on this
always okay all right
i am going with raptors
clippers in the finals raptors
clippers didn't sound definitive on that
it's just so weird down here dan the way
teams are playing
and the vulnerabilities of these top
seeds that i didn't see before
simple as that like the lakers they're
kind of they're kind of shooting
like i thought they'd shoot during the
pre-pandemic season
and the bucks they look great in the
exhibition games and i was bullish on
them then
and then they come into the seating
games and don't play quite as well and
giannis
looks a bit out of sorts i i just every
time i watch the raptors and they've
gotten blown out i think at least once
uh during these uh these games but every
time i look at the raptors
they look the most locked in of any team
in this bubble and i i just gotta think
that counts for something are you going
stir crazy we've we've seen some of the
players it feels like going stir crazy
oh no well i have no life what what what
else would i be doing
are you allowed to bring in somebody
who's a friend or is that just
basketball players who are allowed to do
that
yeah i'm actually scrolling instagram as
we speak to you know
see what's what's happening there uh
no no players coaches coaches can
can't do it either so it's players only
players i love i love this
and you've talked about the memo i'm
sure but like as one gm said to me
like he said uh i'm paraphrasing a
little bit here but he's like
when it comes to this players are
playing chess and the nba is playing
checkers you're gonna see
uh an interesting looking aunt thelma
coming into the uh
coming into this bubble well it can't be
any more embarrassing than what happened
to that seattle seahawk
where he had his girlfriend dress up as
a player
and tried to sneak him by security it's
also it's also kind of stupid dan
because
like as long as these these whoever
comes in no matter what they are family
member
you know short time girlfriend like as
long as they
are tested who cares who they bring in
like if you allow them to bring in
whoever they want
as long as they go through the protocols
that prevents them from doing something
crazy like what you're talking about
that prevents them from going to the
golf course and then
having you know uh three people on the
ninth hole and then
four on the tenth hole and somebody you
know comes scrambling in
you know off the green so i just think
as long as they're being tested who
cares
you know who or what or what
relationship they have with the people
that come in
have a great weekend and uh we'll talk
to you next week thank you again chris
you got it dan that's the popular chris
mannix sports illustrated nba
senior writer joining us from the bubble